hi this is Sal Khan founder of the Khan
Academy and I just wanted to let you
know about the breakthrough junior
challenge in conjunction with Khan
Academy and for those of you who aren't
familiar with the breakthrough prize
it's an incredibly prestigious set of
prizes awarded every year to the world's
leading mathematicians biologists
chemists physicists and the idea is to
award people who are literally moving
humanity forward through the sciences
and through mathematics and what we're
doing this year if we're going to extend
it even further where we're going to
have a breakthrough prize for high
school students that's what the
breakthrough junior challenge is and the
idea is is to award people who can
explain things in a new and innovative
ways ways that can open up all of our
minds because the big breakthroughs the
types of things that the breakthrough
prize is award these all start with new
insights new ways of looking at the
universe and the these new ways of
looking at the universe often happened
with the people who are just trying to
look at it it might happen with young
people especially high school students
so we're going to give this prize it's
going to include a scholarship is going
to include a prize for your teacher and
a possible lab for your school and we're
going to give this for students who can
explain an existing concept in a new way
in a way that opens our minds or a new
idea that they came up with or a new
discovery that they came up with so it's
a very exciting thing to be part of I
really believe that we're gonna
hopefully inspire another generation of
potential breakthrough Prize winners and
I think even this this this this
competition is going to open our minds
it's going to it's going to make us all
see the world and in a new and exciting
way and for the and if you win you will
come out here to Silicon Valley and you
will share the stage with both people
from Silicon Valley leaders in the tech
community leaders in science you'll
share a stage with with with the winners
of the breakthrough prize and there'll
be a few Hollywood celebrities out here
it's going to be televised on national
television so this is going to be a
really really really fun event but most
importantly I think we might be able to
move society forward thank you